you ever used your gay privilege card
well on other gay men probably yeah so
what do you want to know I think I know
what you're getting at as it were are
there things I'm able to say and do that
a straight person wouldn't no that would
be the case if I was very left-wing but
I've not got the correct views so you're
basically straight I'm an honorary
straight if not worse I'm even worse
occasionally I hear people saying oh
well Darkness only gets away with
sayings and stuff he's saying because
he's gay and I think they they don't
really understand that's not the case I
see what I think and I defend it pretty
vigorously I think usually I've never
felt that I've had any extra leeway
because I happen to be gay partly
because it's something I don't talk
about very much I don't believe in the
speaking as a prefix and even before I
could identify what I didn't like about
it I didn't like it